مشاهدينا اهلا بكم شكرا لاحمد وانا ميسون
عزام احييكم وساعه جديده نخصص معظم هذه
الساعه لتطورات الاحداث في السودان
البدايه من العناوين
[موسيقى]
الجيش السوداني يبسط سيطرته على منطقه
كوبر وسلاح الاشاره بالخرطوم بحري
الصحه السودانيه توثق اكثر من 207 حالات
وفاه والاف الاصابات جراء الاشتباكات
وفي هذه النشره ايضا
روسيا تشدد الاجراءات الامنيه في موسكو
بعد هجوم المسيرتين
واشنطن في تورطها
تحقيق اسرائيليه يكشف خللا في منظومه
القبه الحديديه خلال التصعيد الاخير بغزه
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا مع استمرار المواجهات بين
الجيش والدعم السريع منذ هذا الصباح والتي
وصفت بالاعنف منذ بدء الصراع فدم رجل
العربيه بان الجيش سيطر على منطقه كوبر
وايضا سلاح الاشاره في الخرطوم بحري فيما
تقوم قوات الجيش بتمشيط منطقه كوبر بعد
السيطره عليها اظهرت الصور استهدافا جويا
لتمركزات الدعم السريع في محيط القصر
الجمهوري وايضا القياده العامه بالخرطوم
في هذه الاثناء لا تزال الاوضاع الانسانيه
والطبيه في تفاقم مستمر فبينما اعلنت
وزاره الصحه ان 70% من المستشفيات باتت
خارج الخدمه لجا سودانيون للفرار من
الاقتتال الدائر وسط مخاوف من ارتفاع موجه
النزوح لارقام قياسيه
اذا مشاهدينا في تفاصيل ما افاده مراسل
العربيه حول اندلاع معارك عنيفه في
الخرطوم دوت الانفجارات منذ الصباح في
محيط القصر الجمهوري والقياده العامه
للجيش مراسل العربيه اكد ان الخرطوم تشهد
اشتباكاته الاعنف منذ بدء الصراع وتشهد
العاصمه تحليقا للطيران الحربي للجيش
وبشكل مكثف اما في ام درمان فتشهد المدينه
اطلاقا كثيفا لقذائف المدفعيه بين
الجانبين
طبعا لم تتوقف الاتهامات المتبادله بخرق
الهدنه بين الجيش والدعم السريع في اخرها
اتهم بيانات الدعم السريع قوات الجيش بشن
قصف عشوائي على عدد من مواقع تمركز قواتها
وبعض الاحياء السكنيه رغم الهدنه الجديده
التي بدا سير ريانها اليوم بيان الدعم
السريع اكد ان القصف الذي شنه الجيش
بالمدافع والطائرات يشكل تجاوزا للاعراف
والقوانين الدوليه في المقابل اكد الجيش
ان قوات الدعم السريعه حاولت الهجوم على
قياده منطقه بحر العسكريه الجيش السوداني
اضاف ان قواته دمرت عددا من العربات
القتاليه التابعه للدعم السريع واستلمت 15
عربات تم تركها في ميدان المعركه
وقد اظهرت لقطات جويه تصاعد الدخان في
مواقع التي يعتقد ان قيادات للدعم السريعه
تتمركز فيها في الخرطوم بحري مقابل القصر
الجمهوري تحديدا في حي حله حمد وايضا
المنطقه الصناعيه وحي الاملاك دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
هذا ونشر الجيش السوداني مقطع مصور
للمركبات والاسلحه التابعه للدعم السريع
بعد اشتباكات الاخيره في محيط سلاح
الاشاره بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم اخر المعلومات
والتطورات الميدانيه على الارض تفضل
متواصله لكن
في محطه
في مدينه الحكومه
الصوت غير واضح سالم
احسن الان تفضل
في محيط مطار الخرطوم ومحيط كذلك القياده
العامه للجيش وبعض المدن الاخرى التي
تجددت فيها الاشتباكات كمدينه بحريه وكذلك
مدينه
سالم يبدو ان هناك مشكله بالصوت نعود اليك
بعد قليل
ربما تغير موقعك او شيء ما ونتحدث عما
يحدث على الارض ولكن دعني اكمل حول تطورات
في دارفور والي الولايه ولايه الشمال حذر
من وقوع كارثه انسانيه بمخيمات النازحين
بعد ان قامت المنظمات الامميه العامله في
المجال الانساني باجلاء موظفيها بسبب
تدهور الوضع الامني وقال ان الوضع
الانساني بالولايه ينذر بكارثه حقيقيه قبل
ان يعرب عن قلق حكومته تجاه التطورات
الحاصله
هذا ويعيش للعاملون في محطات توليد
الكهرباء في جنوب دارفور مدينه نيالا
اوضاعا صعبه مع استمرار المواجهات
احنا زياره تمت يعني بناء المبادره
واخواننا في الكهرباء واخواننا الاتراك
واخواننا السائق اللواري اللي بيحملوا
حقيقه الوقود من بورسودان لنيال يعني
هلقيت جينا فقدنا اهوالهم وشفناهم والان
احنا في مسقعه انه كيف يفتح الطريق عشان
كل الناس
الكميه من الشكاوي يعني تعرضوا يمكن
ويتعرضوا لكثير من الحاجات مثل هذا
المشاكل اكيد يعني كل زول نصيبه من الشيل
حصل له يعني ولذلك يحتسبون الله لكن خلاص
الناس قادرين انه يقفوا معاهم لحد ما يرجى
باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى فاننا امرنا في
الله كبير ونعمل في علم السودان كلها يعني
باذن الله سبحانه
حتى الناس كلهم توقف صوت الصله وتحتكمل
صوت الاكل من السودان محتاج الان للحزه
السودان يعني تعرضنا لحاله والله بتجيد
صعبه صعبه بكل صعوبه يعني سته ايام مرت
علينا قبل كذا ما حصلت علينا سته ايام نهب
وسلب وبفضل الاله وبحمد الله ومن بعده
لاخواننا في الدعم السريع والله هم يعني
انقذونا ادعمونا ماديا ومع نبيا
وفي اخر تطورات عمليات الاجلاء واصلت
نيجيريا اجلاء المئات من رعاياها الفرينه
من القتال في السودان واعادتهم الى بلادهم
بعد ايام من التاخير الذي ترك العديد منهم
عالقين كانت مفوضيه نيجيريين في الشتات قد
اوضحت في وقت سابق ان حوالي الفين جيري
تقطعت بهم السبل منذ بدء الاشتباكات في
السودان
لقد راينا الرصاصه يمر من امامنا واضطرنا
الى الاستلقاء على الارض لا يمكنك حتى
الجلوس لان سماع الضجيج سيء للغايه
وتستطيع ان تراه بام عينك لم اختبر مثل
هذا الوضع من قبل ففي شهر رمضان ونحن
صائمون لا يوجد طعام ولا ماء واصوات
الرصاص في كل مكان
واحده من سلاح الجو النيجيري لكن التقدير
الكلي على متن الرحله هو حوالي 350 شخصا
وفي هذا الاطار قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الاثيوبيه انه تم تسهيل عبور ما لا يقل عن
4000 شخص من جنسيات مختلفه عبر المنافذ
الحدوديه مع السودان طبعا بالاضافه
لاستقبال اكثر من الف لجه سودانيه
حتى الان تم تسهيل عبور اكثر من 4000 شخص
من احدى 60 دوله عبر المنافذ الحدوديه مع
السودان وتم السماح ل 75 رحله جويه لعبور
الاجواء الاثيوبيه لاجلاء رعاياها من
السودان انطلاقا من مسؤولياتنا ما يحدث في
السودان سيكون له تاثير سلبي على اثيوبيا
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه اضاف ان بلاده تدعم
جهود وساطه الامم المتحده والاتحاد
الافريقي ومنظمه الايجاد مشيرا الى ان
الجهود الاحاديه ستؤذن من الوضع في
السودان نتابع
الوضع الحالي في السودان ستكون له تاثيرات
سلبيه علينا نتابع الوضع السوداني بقلق
بالغ ونؤكد تاييدنا دور الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه ايجاد في
الوساطه بين اطراف الصراع السوداني ونؤمن
بان الحوار هو الحل الوحيد للازمه
وفي متابعه للاوضاع الطبيه كشف المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه دكتور محمد
ابراهيم للعربيه كشف عن توقف 93 مستشفى عن
العمل والخدمه من اصل 143 وذلك في مناطق
النزاع مؤكدا ان هناك اكثر من 200 حاله
وفاجراء الاشتباكات تم توثيقها حتى الان
عدد الاصابات 3,02 اصابه في الغطائين
العام الخاص الوفيات وسبعه حاله وفاه في
القطاعين العام والخاص وهذه موثقه اما
بتحويل الى المشرحه او شهادات الوفاء هذه
من واقع السجلات الطبيه والارغام
الاحصائيه بالمؤسسات الصحيه بالنسبه لعدد
المستشفيات في ولايه الخرطوم يوجد 134
مستشفى عام يتبع للغطاء العام والقطاع
الخاص هذه المستشفيات موزعه على السبع
محليات التي تشكل ولا تخلطون
الذي يعمل فيها منها واحد
ثلاثه تدعيم مستشفى بخروج عدد اثنين
مستشفى اليوم
المزيد معنا من الخرطوم بحري الصحفي محمد
اسحاق عثمان اهلا بك استاذ محمد اخر
المعلومات المتوفره لديك حول التطورات
الميدانيه تفضل
مرحبا بيسون لا زالت عمليات التنشيط تستمر
في محيط منطقه كوبر التي شهدت معارك قويه
جدا في الساعات الفائته
ايضا علمنا ان كذلك تستمر المعارك في محيط
الاذاعه والتلفزيون في منطقه ام درمان
وكذلك لازمنا نشاهد هذه الاعاب الدخانيه
التي تاتينا واضح بانها من جنوب الخرطوم
هذه المعارك ميسون في الساعات الاخيره تم
تجفيفها بصوره واضحه الجيش الان واضح بانه
يعمل على عدد من المحاور اندرمان والخرطوم
جنوب وكذلك العمليات التي دارت قبل ساعتها
بعد ذكرت في منطقه الخرطوم بحري في سلاح
الاشاره حيث تم الاحتداء كما علمنا او
محاولات للاعتداء على السيطره على سلاح
الاشاره ولكن الجيش قام بعمليات كبيره جدا
وكبده بحسب الفيديوهات التي تابعناها قوات
الدعم السريع كثير من الخسائر طيب عندما
نتحدث انه اليوم بالنسبه للاشتباكات تعتبر
الاعنف الاعنف بكثافتها
بالمده التي استمرت فيها ان بطبيعه
الاسلحه المستخدمه محمد
نعم بالاثنين ميسون لان معركه بحري
اختبارات اكثر من اربع ساعات كذلك بحسب
التكتيك او التكنيك الجديد الذي اعلن عنه
الجيش تحت مسمى هذه الضربات الحاسبه لان
اليوم سيكون يوم قاسي جدا على هذه القوات
قوات الدعم السريع بعد المعركه القويه
التي
دار في وسط الخرطوم عمل الجيش هذه المره
يبدو انه دخل الان بمبدا انهاك هذه القوات
واستنزافها لذلك فتح اكثر من من جبهه
للقتال في اكثر في المكان مما يجعل
بالتواصل بين هذه القوات التي يقال لان
اصل التواصل بينها منعدم مما يتسبب في
الانهاق والارهاق بهذه القوات بالقتال في
اكثر من مكان في وقت واحد ماذا عن الخسائر
الماديه والبشريه
التسجيلات عرضها الجيش طلعنا عليها قبل
قليل
بالسيطره في منطقه كوبر على اكثر من سبعه
عربات مقاتله كذلك في منطقه وسط الخرطوم
عدد كبير من
الجرحى
المصابين
والذين لقوا حذفهم في هذه العمليات وكذلك
عدد كبير من العربات القتاليه والمقاتله
سيطر عليها الجيش بحسرنا ورد في
الفيديوهات التي قام بنشرها مؤخرا بالنسبه
للخسائر البشريه هل من احصاءات او لا
بطبيعه الحال كما ذكرت قبل قليل اصابات
كبيره وقتل جثث
الان متناثره في الشواهد التقليب في منطقه
كوبري
لم نستطيع حتى الان من تحديد ارقام
للمعركه توها الان يعمل الجيش في مرحله
التمشيط توها انتهت مرحله المعركه فلذلك
بذلت الاحصاءات بالنسبه للجثث يظهر في وقت
الحالي ولكن عدد العربات التي سيطر عليها
الجيش في منطقه كوبر يقول بانها اكثر من
10 ضربات مقاتله طيب عندما تتحدث انه يصعب
حصر اعداد الضحايا من جراء هذه الاشتباكات
هل هناك امكانيه لتواقم الاسعاف للتحرك او
ايضا هذا صعب جدا
علمنا ايضا بان الاسعاف عموما هذه واحده
من الملاحظات ميسون فعلا يعني بعد انتهاء
المعارك يصعب
المناطق التي كانت بها اشتباكات ذلك يعود
لعدد من القناصين الذين تجدهم في اعلى
البنايات في
المناطق الاشتباك يعني بالامس على سبيل
المثال وسط الخرطوم كانت ممتلئه هذه
البدايات العاليه للقداسين ومما يتسبب في
اشكاليات في اندلاء او للتدخل لاسعاف بعض
الذين اصيبوا مما يتسبب في مزيد من
الكوارث الطرفين سواء كان من الجيش او من
قوات الدعم السريع طيب هذا بالنسبه
للتواقم الطبيه ماذا عن المواطنين وماذا
عن عمليات النزوح كيف تاثرت اليوم
نعم عمليات النزوح الواضح والمشاهد بان
نسبه التاثير لم تكن كبيره عليها لان
الحافلات التي تقل هؤلاء الذين يودون
مغادره الخرطوم يتواجد في منطقه جسر
الحلفايه هذه المنطقه الان هي اكثر هدوءا
لذلك تجد فيها الحافلات السفريه دائما ما
تقول في هذه المنطقه متجمعه اليوم شاهدنا
مزيد من الحافلات دخلت للخدمه موجوده في
هذه المنطقه تقول المسافرين والذين يودون
مقابل الخرطوم كلهم يتجمعون في هذه
المنطقه ياتون من مناطق مختلفه سواء كان
في ام درمان مستغلين جسر الحلفايه او في
شرق النيل او في الضواحي منطقه بحري شمال
مصر الحلفاء الامور في مجره ابو قادره
القرطبي هذه الحافلات تسير بصوره طبيعيه
طيب على كل شكرا جزيلا من الخرطوم بحري
الصحفي محمد اسحاق عثمان على هذه
المعلومات والمشاركه
ومن الخرطوم معنا مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم كنت قد سالتك عن
المعلومات المتوفره لديك حول التطورات
الميدانيه تفضل
نعم اخر التطورات تجدد الاشتباكات في
مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم ابرزها
مدينه الخرطوم في محيط القصر الرئاسي
ومحيط القياده العامه للجيش كذلك يتجددت
الاشتباكات في مدينه بحري في محيط حي سوبر
وبالقرب من جسر كوبر كذلك في هذه المنطقه
شهيده اشتباكا عنيفا وقصفا بطائرات في تلك
المنطقه
وكذلك في مدينه ام درمان منذ فجر اليوم
الان تبدو الاوضاع الى هدوء نسبي في مناطق
متفرقه مع تحليق للطائرات وسماح لمضادات
الطائرات
نعم وكنا نتحدث قبل قليل من خرطوم بحري عن
الخسائر البشريه وقال ان هناك ليس من رفض
اي معلومات وصلت اليك حول اعداد ضحايا
الاشتباكات
وحجمها بالمقابل مقارنه بالايام السابقه
كيف يمكن ان نفرق ونقيم
نعم يسعد الحديث عن تفاصيل هذا الموضوع
الان خاصه وانها بالمنطقه يصعب الدخول
اليها في هذا التوقيت لكن بالنظر الى
اشتباكات اليوم
لحده وسيرتها ربما تكون هنالك خسائر
وحصائر فادحه كذلك بحكم انها منذ فتره
اليوم بدا القصف عنيفا كان يشبه بالفعل
الايام الاولى لهذه الاشتباكات كان قصف
عنيف في مناطق متفرقه
من العاصمه الخرطوم وفي مدن العاصمه كلها
ام درمان وبحري والخرطوم كذلك الى الان
نسمع عزيزي الطائرات في هذه اللحظات وما
زلنا كذلك نستمع الى اصوات مضادات الطائره
وماذا عن اصوات المفاوضات
والحراك هل من حراك نشط اليوم ام انه مجمد
ماذا تقول بذلك
نعم الحراك بالنسبه للحراك في موضوع
المفاوضات على الارض لا وجود لهذه
المفاوضات الان على ما نراه على الارض
وحده اشتباكات بل ان الانباء الان
تتواتر راح التوتر في مدينه الغيط في غرب
غرب السودان لمدينه الابيض وهي حاضره
ولايه شمال كردفان
هذه المدينه ايضا تتواردي من الانباء بان
هنالك عربات غربيه المدينه تتبع لقوات
الدعم السريع وانها يعني في تاخر للهجوم
على مناطق متفرقه للجيش السوداني في
مدينه الاوبيض والان مدينه تشهد هدوءا
عاما فخذوا من الشوارع حتى سوق الابيض
الان خالي من المواطنين في هذه اللحظات
قبل قليل كنا نتواصل مع
مقاديرنا في مدينه الاوبيض تحدثوا على ان
هناك حذر سمعت اصوات بعض الطلقات الناريه
وكذلك اصوات لكن لا يعلم المواطنون ما
الذي يجري في تلك المدينه الان بعد ان
كانت عمها الهدوء في الايام الماضيه وكانت
تعيش حياه طبيعيه كامله وكيف
يقرا راقبون هذه التحولات الان يوم اول
وجديد في هذه الهدنه يعتبر الاعنف فيما
يتعلق بالاشتباكات نشاهد هذه الصور
المباشره من قلب العاصمه الخرطوم كما ذكرت
الدخان يتصاعد حتى الان في اشاره الى
الاشتباكات التي كانت والقصف ربما الذي
رافق هذه الاشتباكات كيف يرى المراقبون
ويقرؤون المشهد الان تحرك نشط فيما يتعلق
بالمفاوضات لا يتمثل ابدا على ارض الواقع
بل يزيده ان كان في الرقعه كما ذكرت
الابيض عادت لتشتعل فيما يبدو وايضا في
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
اليوم واستمرت حتى ما يقارب الساعه
الواحده ثم بدات في الوتيره تنخفض حتى هذه
اللحظات الان هناك هدوء نسبي في ارجاء
العاصمه الخرطوم في هذه اللحظات عدا اعمده
الدخان التي تنطلق من اماكن متفرقه من
العاصمه من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي شكرا جزيلا لك
ومعنا من الخرطوم ايضا رئيس لجنه السياسات
في حزب الام القومي امام الحلو اهلا بك
سيد امام اسمح لي ان ابدا بقراءتك للمشهد
اين يكمن الخلل ما بين الحديث من جهه عن
مفاوضات وعن ممثلين لطرفي النزاع وعلى
الارض نشهد تصعيد ربما يفوق ما سبقوا من
ايام من اشتباكات وايضا من قصف
ومرحب بقناه العربيه مشاهدي قناه العربيه
مشهد مؤسف الان
بهدن السابعه
والفاشله وانا اعتقد انه هذا يعني اجابه
نتائج عكسيه موضوع الهدن اصبح فيها القتل
اكثر
ويعني يبقى اذا لا فائده من هذه
الطريقه في وقف القتال
وانا ارجو ان من المجتمع الدولي والدول
الوقفه هذه العمليه
بما يسمى بالهدنه المؤقته لم تاتي سبعه
وفشلت بل بالعكس القتل فيها والصدام في
فتره ولذلك انا اعتقد
ان الهدنه فشلت وربما هذه المره في ظلمه
تم الحديث عنهم بانه الاشتباكات هي الاعنف
ربما
بجداره ولكن هل تعتقد انه وقف حتى الحديث
عن هدى سيساعد اكثر في ايجاد الحلول ام
انه سيعزز من الصراع والاقتتال اكثر فاكثر
على الاقل يعني الاشتباكات متقطعه الان
يا سيدتي واضح انه في اثناء الهدنه يشتد
القتال نتيجه لانه الرغبه الطرفين في كسب
اكبر مساحه للتفاوض
وجابت نتائج سلبيه يجب ان تقف الان هذه
المدن يجب ان نبحث عن طريق اخر الطريق
الاخر وهو ان مثلا تجربه الشمال دارفورد
القوى الوطنيه عليها انها تتخذ موقف
ايجابي اكثر وانها تخاطب الطرفين
وتحمل الطرفين من نتائج الصدام الدموي
اللي السودان الان في الخرطوم او في مدن
اخرى الان
الموقف المدني السياسي القوه السياسي عليه
وهو ان يعلو على المعرفه العسكريه الان
ويجب ان
اخواننا في
الان في طرفي النزاع يجب ان يعلموا ان
الشعب السوداني له موقف وله رايك ويجب ان
يحترم هذا الراي الامام انه التحركات من
المكون المدني لم تكن كافيه لانه بحسب ما
شاهدنا بالفتره الاخيره محاوله للملمه
الصفوف الموقف واحد وممدد طبعا
بما يحدث وهناك مطالبه كامله لوقف اطلاق
النار اضافه حتى وصلت الى الدعوه لخروج
الناس في الشارع في الاماكن
الهادئه على الاقل ماذا يمكن ان يفعلوا
اكثر من ذلك برايك لم يفعلوه
نحن في حزب الامه منذ اليوم الاول طرحنا
مبادره بتشكيل لجنه مشتركه من الطرفين
النزاع
وطرف ثالث من الشخصيات القوميه للبحث في
وقف القتال وكيفيه
اليات تنفيذ هذا الوقف وانا اعتقد انه
الان يمكن يمكن توحيد القوه القوه
السياسيه خلف الشعب السوداني كله الان
مجمع على انه هذه الحرب هو دمار بالنسبه
له ويرفض هذه الحرب ويدين الطرفين
الاستمرار في هذا الصراع الدموي اذا
المجتمع المدني السوداني هو ينبغي ان
يتحرك بصوره اكثر من مظاهرات في الشارع او
اي تمديد او عندنا سوزان خارج الحدود انه
يتحرك السودان في داخل الحدود لماذا برايك
لا يتحرك لا لم يتحرك بشكل سيدي امام هل
هي الانشقاقات اللي كانت تعصف بهذه الوحده
في المكون المدني ام ماذا
نعم صحيح ينبغي الان تجاوز هذه الخلافات
تماما وينبغي توحيدها نحن الان في ذلك كل
القوه السياسيه والمدنيه الان نعمل على
توحيده في موقف واحد محدد في وقت هذا
الصباع والان يعني اطروحات كثيره مبادرات
ان شاء الله انها تتجمع في السرعه اللازمه
بحيث انها يعني
تؤثر في قرار القيادات العسكريه الان في
الميدان واضح ان داخل السوداني قادر على
التاثير على طرفي النزاع اكثر من ما طرح
من انه مبادره من ايجاد وايضا من اكثر من
دوله تتحرك بهذا الاطار
انا اعتقد انه
المبادله الايجاز مع احترامنا اليوم
مبادره الولايات المتحده والسعوديه مع
احترامنا وكافه المبادرات الخارجيه هي
يعني لا تكفيه انما يجب ان تكون مساعده
نحن لا نطلب اي تدخل عسكري من اي دوله
خارجيه الان انما العسكري سيد امام
هذه المبادرات ربما
حلول مثل هذه الاشياء نحن لا نقول ذلك
ولكن نحن يعني في القوه السياسيه المدنيه
نامل من قاده الطرفين المتنازعين
لصوت العقل وسماع الراي الشعب السوداني
يمثل في هذاك السياسيه المدنيه ونعتقد انه
الان الان ان طرفي النزاع غير معنيين بهذه
النقطه وبالتالي ما هي الاوراق
التي يمكن استخدامها بهذا الاطار
على على صعيد القوه السياسيه المدنيه اذا
توحدت هذه القوه في الجبهه وطنيه واحده
واعلنت مواقفها تجبر لانه لانه المستقبل
هو في القرار المدني وليس في القرار
العسكري وده لا بد من انه مهما طال زمن
القتال الان سينتهي هذه المدرسه سواء كان
بدمار او غيره لا بد من التحول الديمقراطي
الطرفين اللي بيتحدثوا عنه ولكن واضح انه
لم تكن هناك جديه في هذه المزد ولكن نحن
نؤمن تماما ان المستقبل هو للتحول المدني
الديمقراطي ويعني القوه المدنيه انها تعمل
بقوه في اطار العمل الجماهيري والعمل
السلمي نحن لا نستعمل سلاح ولا عندنا اي
شيء غير العمل السلمي والضغط الدولي اللي
نحن نطال بانه يعمل على بكافه السبل
الدبلوماسيه
والمنظمات الانسانيه في انها توقف هذا
القتل الان ثم اعاده نحن في داخل السودان
الان
نسعى لتجميع هذه القوه الشعبيه الوطنيه
بحيث ان يكون عندها صوت معلوم ومسموع
لطرفيه النزاع وخالتهم ونحن نامل من
القاده انه يحتكم على صوت العقل ويسمع صوت
ابناء السودان وهناك تجربه الان في بعض
المناطق استمعت لها قيادات هذه الاطراف
المتنازعه
وتفادت الصدام الدموي الان في الخرطوم وفي
بعض المدن نامل انه يتحقق هذا العمل
بالسرعه اللازمه من الخرطوم رئيس لجنه
السياسات في حزب الامه القوميه امام الحلو
شكرا جزيلا لك
عرب الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيرس عن اسفه لاخفاق المنظمه في وقف
الحرب في السودان حيث تقود المعارك
المستمره جهود
ترسيخال ان الامم المتحده فوجئت بتفجر
العنف في السودان ولم تتوقع تطور الاحداث
بهذه السرعه شدد على ضروره التحرك بصفه
مستعجله ووقف كافه اشكال التصعيد وايجاد
حل يعيد السودان الى بر الامان والسعي الى
تحقيق الاستقرار والوحده
هذا واظهرت صور اقمار صناعيه
حريق في مطار الخرطوم الدولي مع استمرار
المواجهات نتابع
[موسيقى]
وفي اخر تطورات عمليات النزوح يواصلوا
مئات السودانيين نزوحهم نحو مصر فارينا من
المعارك المستمره بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في الايام الماضيه
شهدت المعابر البريه الجنوبيه بين مصر
والسودان شهدت ازدحاما شديدا لعبور عشرات
الحافلات التي تقل السودانيين والاجانب
المقيمين بالبلاد الى مصر
على
حسن الاداه والضيافه والمعامله ولكن في
بعض النواقص تشير اليها تكدس عالي جدا
يحتاج الى خدمات اسرع
الناس جايه بتنشن عالي جدا بنك حاله بتاعه
حرب فرجاء
يعني مناوله ومداوله الامر باسرع في تقدس
كثير في حلفا في هذه المشكله
يعني اعتمر عالقينهم العالقين بجمهوريه
يعني جمهوريه مصر العربيه هم قاعدين نحسب
حلفا يعني شغال من السودان برفع مواطنين
من المعبره للسوداني لابو سمبل
لكركر لاسوان
الحركه شويه اليومين دي يعني صعبه يعني
مال الحروبات والمشاكل
ومشاهدينا كما تتابعون على العواجل الرئيس
وزراء اليابان يتحدث عن ان مجموعه السبع
ستعمل على تحقيق الاستقرار في السودان
استقرار في وقت تشهد فيه هذه الهدنه
الجديده اشتباكات وصفت بانها الاعنف
الدخان يتصاعد من اكثر من بقعه في العاصمه
الخرطوم وطبعا نشاهد هذه الصور الان لهذا
الدخان
المتصاعد وفي معظمه يدور من اشتباكات في
معظمها تدور في منطقه القوات المسلحه
وايضا القصر الجمهوري
وفي تصريحات للعربيه اعرب سفير الاتحاد
الاوروبي في القاهره كريستيان برجر عن
قلقه من الحرب في السودان اضاف ان تعامل
مصر بحرص على حدودها مبرر حتى لا يتسلل
الارهابيون اليها
نحن قلقون عندما تدور اشتباكات مثل هذه
وتتحول الى حرب لان هذا يعطي المساحه
دائما لذوي الافكار المتطرفه والارهابيه
اننا نرى ما تفعله مصر الان وهي تتعامل
بحرص على الحدود لتتاكد من عدم تسرب
ارهابيين من خلال حدودها مع السودان
واعتقد اننا سنناقش هذا على المستوى
الثنائي مع نظرائنا المصريين لنرى امكانيه
التعاون في هذا الموضوع
هذا ويشكل استمرار القتال في السودان
وايضا تدفق الاف الفرينه الى دول الجوار
من بينها مصر يشكل ضغوط على اقتصاد البلاد
وعلى امنها القومي خصوصا وان تبعات الحرب
الروسيه والاوكرانيه ما تزال تلقي بظلالها
على مصر بحسب مراقبين دعمنا نتابع
الاف السودانيين يتدفقون يوميا عبر
المعابر البريه مع مصر هربا من القتال في
بلدانهم تدفق يثير مخاوف السلطات المصريه
بسبب التاثيرات السلبيه المتوقعه على
اقتصاد البلاد الذي يعاني بالفعل من تبعات
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه بالاضافه
لاستضافه مصر لملايين اللاجئين من دول
عربيه خلال الاعوام الماضيه في دعم دولي
لهذا الموضوع عشان خاطر نقدر ان احنا
نتحمل ولا سيما ان احنا عندنا فوق الخمسه
مليون سوداني موجودين بالفعل واجمالي زي
ما صرح سياده الرئيس اجمالي اللي موجودين
اللاجئين يفوق 9 مليون الوضع على الحدود
اثر بالفعل على حركه تنقل البضائع بين
البلدين عشرات الناقلات تعجز عن المرور في
الاتجاهين
انا بقى لي 25 يوم
وطبعا الخسائر دي ان العربيه واقفه وانا
واقف وصاحب البضاعه ما هوش عاوز يقول ارجع
على اساس ان الحال يصلح ونخش فانا طبعا ما
هوش هنخش مستحيل ان احنا نخش بعد الضرب ده
وبعيدا عن الاقتصاد فان كثيرين يحذرون من
تداعيات استمرار المواجهات في السودان
وزياده اعداد النازحين على الامن القومي
المصري فهناك خشيه من محاولات استغلال
الفوضى لتسلل عناصر من الجماعات المتطرفه
لدخول الاراضي المصريه في حدود مفتوحه مع
ليبيا وبالتالي ممكن ان يكون هذا ممر
للعناصر الارهابيه وعناصر القريبه المنظمه
دائما ما ترتبط الارهاب بعناصر الجريمه
المنظمه العناصر بيوفروا الدعم اللازم
سواء المادي او المعنوي او اللوجستي
للعناصر الارهابيه وبالتالي هذه العناصر
دي بتلاقي في الحاله بتلاقي فيه ملاذ امن
القاهره مستمره في العمل مع شركائها
الاقليميين والدوليين في محاوله لوقف
القتال وتثبيت الهدن وعوده الاستقرار
للسودان وتبقى الامال معقوده على نجاح
مبادرات الدوليه والاقليميه في اقناع طرفي
نزاع في وقف الاقتتال حتى لا تتفاقم
الاثار السلبيه على جميع دول الجوار احمد
عثمان العربيه من معبر ارجيل على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه
اما في بوتسودان فقد تسببت المواجهات
المسلحه بين الجيش والدعم السريع في توقف
حركه الاف من شاحنات نقل البضائع من
الميناء الرئيسي في بورتسودان الى مختلف
الولايات السودانيه فيما يتخوف اصحاب
الشاحنات التي تحمل الامدادات من القمح
والوقود والمواد الاساسيه من اطاله امد
الصراع
المواجهات المسلحه القت بظلال سلبيه على
قطاعات حيويه ومهمه في البلاد هنا في شرق
السودان تبرز معاناه سائق الشاحنات
المتوقفين عن العمل كواحده من تداعيات
الاوضاع الامنيه في السودان
والله المشكله انه العربات دي شاحنه وطبعا
الوضع من وما قادرين نتحركوا يعني عندنا
عربات قميص طلعت
اول نقطه بتاعه عبور ونرجعها عشان الاساس
انه البلد ما في امان
دي اكبر مشكله مننا ناس
رمضان لغايه الان ما قادرين تتحرك هو
عربات شحن وقاعده بس
زي ما شايفين اهو شاحن واقف والله شاحنين
سكر شاحنين دقيق
وحدين الخرطوم وواحدين الابيض
البحر الاحمر مطالبها وتتحدث عن خسائر
باهظه كمرحين اصحاب شاحنات
تقريبا متوقفه 90% او زياده يعني هذا من
جانب اما بقيه الملفات الخدميه والتنمويه
فان السلطات في ولايه البحر الاحمر تؤكد
العمل على استقرار الاوضاع والتعاطي
بايجابيه مع قضيه اجلاء رعايا الدول
الاجنبيه الوضع الامني بصفه عامه على
مستوى العشره محليات
الامن في جهازي الولايه يمكن الحياه تصير
بصوره طبيعيه كما شاهدتموها ايضا الاسواق
النشاط التجاري بصوره ممتازه الحياه بصوره
طبيعيه ما شاء الله ما عندنا مشاكل اياميه
يمكن بالاخوه
العالقين حتى ما غادروا السودان نحن عن
طريق التنسيق مع منظمات المجتمع المدني
والاخوه الخيرين في مدينه بورسودان الان
تم اعداد ما يقارب سبعه مناطق قوى منتشره
بورسان تقدم فيها كل الخدمات مما شربها
وجبات يمكن الثلاثه وجبات لم تقدم هؤل
الاخوه
والبرنامج بصوره ممتازه جدا نزار البداوي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث من مدينه بورسودان
شرقي السودان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات